hey guys it is the ninth of July today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
tuned into games but news well guys our
days of raising tiny crawling humans and
hanging out by lavish awesome pools are
over because the sims ball weren't have
toddlers or pools max's has come out
today to try and explain why the
immediate assumption jumped to by gamers
and anybody who's ever been to a gaming
store and seen the 400 million sims
expansions is that these features will
probably appear somewhere in an add-on
for five to twenty bucks depending on
your region or if you're my producer you
understand that babies plus bulls plus
the internet equals terrible things
developer max this is stress that the
absence of these features isn't
occurring out of greed but instead their
desire to create a new technology the
devil claiming that to include said
technology which encompasses new AI
animations routing intelligence and what
have you they've had to sacrifice some
things in a trade off Ubisoft had come
out to say that far cry fourth map size
will be the same as far cry 3 s and at
this time in the gaming industry where
everybody loves to compare map sizes he
is expecting people to worry but they're
saying it's not really the size that
matters but how you use it game director
Alex Hutchinson told Game Informer that
they focused on building a world that is
more alive in his words it was trying to
pack in more events where you come
across NPCs more events where you come
across enemies doing unusual stuff the
first person action game will also
feature calmer events where you can
perform side missions to help out the
locals or what have you elsewhere in the
interview he revealed that there are no
sharks but there are demon fish and
honey badgers sure all right next up
Assassin's Creed unity is set to take
full advantage of the power of the ps4
and Xbox one and that line is getting
really stale Bob's more interestingly
apparently unity is going to be the best
entry point for people since the Saxons
Creed one unity is set to be a new
starting point in the series with a
whole new approach to the modern-day
story which is such a staple for
Assassin's Creed a new video on ub's
official YouTube channel includes
comments about a new narrative start
which created director Alex Amancio
plains is symbolized by a completely new
context for the present day you've seen
a bit of evolution with black flag we're
not going to do the same thing what
we're going to do with unity is really
the beginning of this new cycle of
Assassin's Creed games playstation
worldwide studios boss Shuhei Yoshida
has suggested that the last of us may
not be among the last of the games are
planning to remaster for ps4 Yoshida
told Eurogamer there are requests from
some consumers for games that were
released later in the generation like
Uncharted which people might have missed
that would be a good candidate at the
same time he stresses that he doesn't
want to flood the market with remade
games nonetheless you shoot a noted that
half the current owners appear sports
never bought a ps3 so the remakes may
serve some value for gamers who missed
out on the stellar releases from last
gen and your question of the day is
would you play a remastered version of
Uncharted or if you could pick which
game would you want to get an HD
remaster of on ps4 or Xbox one that is
it for me today thanks for listening to
my word pictures and I will see you
again tomorrow